women will do all types of craziness and
have zero consequences for the decisions
that we make um and what made me think
of this is there was a man that actually
cut his wife's head off after DNA proved
six kids were not his now I don't
obviously cutting off the head off was
obviously you know don't do that but but
you know it kind of shows an issue which
one there are many men raising kids that
are not theirs this is common you know
they say of DNA tests that are done a
third of them it's not actually their
kid and that's just a third of the ones
that get tests and you know The Optimist
in me says well maybe that's like a
higher rate because those are the ones
that go get it done right there
suspicion but the pessimist in me thinks
if it's that many you know it's probably
I mean how many guys are walking through
life with no idea of women's like true
like this type of content isn't
mainstream